[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
enlightenment then holds an irresistible
authority over faith because in the
believers own consciousness are found
the very moments which enlightenment has
established as valid examining the
effect of this authority more closely
its behavior towards faith seems to rend
asunder the beautiful unity of trust and
immediate certainty to pollute it's
spiritual consciousness with mean
thoughts of sensuous reality to destroy
the soul which is composed and secure in
its submission by the vanity of the
understanding and of self-will and self
fulfillment but as a matter of fact the
result of the Enlightenment is rather to
do do away with the thoughtless or
rather non notional separation which is
present in faith the believing
consciousness weighs and measures by a
two-fold standard it has two sorts of
eyes two sorts of ears speaks with two
voices has duplicated all ideas without
comparing the twofold meanings in other
words faith lives in two sorts of non
notional perceptions the one the
perceptions of the slumbering
consciousness which lives purely and non
notional thoughts the other those of the
waking consciousness which lives solely
in the world of sense and in each of
them and he has its own separate
housekeeping the Enlightenment
illuminates that heavenly world with
ideas belonging to the world of sense
and points out this finitude which faith
cannot deny because it is self
consciousness and hence as the unity to
which both kinds of ideas belong and in
which they do not fall apart for they
belong to the same indivisible unitary
self into which faith has passed
we've now reached paragraph 572 which is
the penultimate paragraph in this
section of spirits the enlightenment and
its struggle with superstition which of
course the Enlightenment interprets as
faith and one of the things that that
Hegel has been doing for us over and
over again in this section is showing
how dynamic the relationship between
enlightenment and or pure insight if you
like and faith or a religious belief and
religious institutions has been
enlightenment has produced this you know
very complex and thoroughgoing critique
of faith and in doing so has found
within itself the capacities to at least
partially develop its own perspective
although one that remains to some degree
rooted in its its predecessor of faith
right um but it's also helped faith in
some respect to purify itself so this is
not going to be the very end of religion
as a matter of fact if you've read ahead
in the phenomenology you know that
there's going to be an entire religion
section following this long spirit
portion of the work so what's going on
here Hegel tells us that enlightenment
holds an irresistible authority over
faith by this point right why because in
the believers own consciousness are
found the very moments which
enlightenment has established as valid
see here's the thing faith cannot be
shaken unless it wants to take into
account whatever it is that is not faith
so we might think about this in terms of
you know a religious view on things and
and not just view on things but
institution and practices and action
this entire
you know panoply that goes along with
religion and then what we can call using
the very terminology of faith the world
right and at first this was the world of
culture and then it became the world of
pure thought namely the Enlightenment
and its critique now if faith wants to
be genuine and it's to be a spiritual
faith treating the human being as
essentially the locus where you know
human being and divinity meets then it
can't just turn its brain off although
this is what many religious believers
attempt to do right and there are whole
traditions that say just don't think
don't think just believe that's never
satisfying and that's even less
satisfying when we have these incredible
social changes if faith is actually
going to remain faithful not just to its
divinity but also to its own nature it
has to listen to what enlightenment has
to say if it's going to lay claim to
honesty truth it has to take truth where
it finds it and as it turns out the
Enlightenment has a lot to tell it so
Hegel says let's examine the effects of
this authority more closely and here we
have this sort of schema here right it's
behavior enlightenment behavior towards
faith he says seems to rend asunder the
beautiful unity of trust and immediate
certainty something that faith was
providing to the believer if the
believer allows enlightenment to come in
then they start asking questions they
start realizing the discordance between
these that there isn't a pure unity here
he says it seems to pollute it's
spiritual consciousness with mean
thoughts right degrading low thoughts of
what sensuous reality we saw earlier
that enlightenment or pure insight takes
us back to the cent certainty of the
beginning of the very first part of
consciousness but now at a higher level
more developed it pays
attention to the sensuous thing and at
understand spiritual realities as
themselves sensuous things Hagel himself
is rather receptive to this Hagel does
think that we live within a world that
we perceive with our senses if there is
a spiritual reality
it can't be some ghostly thing you know
dualistic aliy floating out there
totally cut off from this sensuous
reality it better inhabit it so how do
we make sense of this enlightenment is
offering a perspective since sensuous
reality understood through sense
certainty Hegel talks about two other
aspects of this as he's calling it this
this mean thoughts right destroying the
soul that is composed and secure in its
submission by the vanity of the
understanding and South will and self
fulfillment the enlightenment it
represents a certain kind of rationality
that is being deployed not against an
irrationality but a previous rationality
that of faith and you might say wait a
second faith and reason those are two
things almost like oil and water they
don't mix well who are you Tertullian
even Tertullian used rational
argumentation and exposition in in
making his you know claim about Athens
and Jerusalem and there are places where
Athens and Jerusalem do in fact meet and
they have to in our day-to-day lives and
they have to whenever we're thinking
important things like faith does there's
a rationality involved in the
consciousness of faith enlightenment is
offering what it takes to be a more
developed rationality one that is based
on you know the understanding for Hegel
the understanding by the way is never
going to be something good in its own
respect because we have here in
opposition between understanding on the
one hand and reason let's call it reason
with a capital R
right Hagel will actually use in his
lectures on the philosophy of religion
philosophies of the understanding as
kind of a pejorative comment to talk
about philosophies of the Enlightenment
they don't go far enough they're not
conceptual they're not actually taking
in the totality of things they're
they're great at classifying
they're great at doing a certain kind of
analysis but they aren't sufficiently
self-aware and they don't assimilate
their opposites rather they attack them
and classify them be that as it may here
we're also talking about self will and
self fulfillment and the person of
enlightenment saying to the person of
faith hey you know why why don't you
behave more rationally when it comes to
what you're sacrificing does it really
as we saw in the previous paragraph does
it really make sense for you to fast or
is that sort of an arbitrary commitment
that you made it's merely symbolic and
it's not really going to get you any any
surcease if you like any ending to this
dialectic of desire and pleasure that
you're caught up in even if you starve
yourself so where do we go from here
Hegel says as a matter of fact the
result of enlightenment is to purify
faith faith at first looks at
enlightenment as if it's destroying
faith but really it's helping it out
he says the result of enlightenment is
to do away with the thoughtless remember
what is faith faith is pure thought but
it has a tendency to get lost within its
own world and its own Beyond right
getting turned into a sort of idolatry
taking the statue for being the thing
taking the individual gesture for being
a universal sacrifice so he says
enlightenment does away with the
thoughtless or rather non notional
separation that is present in faith non
notional wouldn't agree FeliCa
non-conceptual what makes it
non-conceptual it's it's not allowing
these things to be separated and yet
United at the same time it's saying look
either they're separated or they're
United I can't think beyond that you
know and if they're separated all
everything is falling apart no they get
separated and they also are connected in
that very separation in that relation
Hegel goes on and he says the believing
consciousness weighs and measures by a
two-fold standard it has two sets of
eyes two sets of ears speaks with two
voices has duplicated all ideas without
comparing the twofold meanings what's he
talking about there why this sort of
repetition two to two because one of the
things that happens with religious
belief is the sort of projection of a
world out there that's the real world
you know
Nietzsche of course calls calls
Christianity platonism for the masses
Hegel could say something quite like
that in terms of what he's talking about
here in faith so you know there are the
eyes that we see with and then there are
the eyes of the heart or the eyes of the
mind you know there are the ears that
hear at the sort of surface level and
then there are the ears that hear the
true meaning behind a parable right
there are two voices the voices that one
speaks with out here in the world and
then sort of an inner voice and we can
go on and on and on with this you know
we could talk about if we want to
multiply this metaphor there are two
kinds of money's or talents there are
you know two types of fathers or mothers
and go on and on and on with this and
the problem is not Hegel is saying here
that we do have this bifurcation the
problem is that they're being separated
out and faith is not adequately
reconnecting them so notice that
distinction there the problem is not
that they're being separated into two
the problem is that there's no real
connection being worked out between them
the plenty of arbitrary connections you
might think if you know your you know
medieval biblical commentaries which I
don't take for granted anybody listening
or watching this does but you might
think about the abuses of the
allegorical method that that some
commentators got into or just about
anything could mean anything else right
we want there to be some sort of reason
why things are connected to each other
prime example of this is if you think
about the parables within the the
Gospels you know what are these stories
supposed to teach there are you know
some interesting cases where the the one
who's giving the parable actually says
okay let me break this down for you
because you might not actually get this
think about the parable of the sower
where instead of just telling this story
about you know the grain being sown here
and there and then things happening to
it like the birds coming along and
eating it or you know it springs up but
it doesn't have any route that stays
there or it does actually prosper you
know he says listen I need to explain
this to you that is conceptual
reconnecting right there so that gives
you an idea of what we're talking about
so he says what's what's the the the
result of this in other words he says
faith lives in two sorts of non notional
perceptions the one the perceptions of
the slumbering consciousness which lives
purely in non notional thoughts non
conceptual thoughts the other that of
the waking consciousness which lives
solely in the world of sense and in each
of them there's a beautiful metaphor it
has its separate housekeeping there is
no unity here there is no bringing
everything within the same household the
same commensurable way of accounting for
things this is a fundamental problem in
Hegel's view so he says the
Enlightenment illuminates that heavenly
world with ideas belonging to the world
of sense and that that seems bad from
the perspective of faith and it points
out this finitude that faith cannot deny
why because he says faith is a
self-consciousness and hence is the
unity to which both kinds of ideas
belong and in which they do not fall
apart for they belong to the same
indivisible unitary self in which faith
has passed so on perhaps a a unconscious
level these these dual isms are being
maintained but they're not being
conceptually understood and that's the
fundamental problem
as a result faith has lost the content
which filled its element and collapses
into a state in which it moves listless
ly to and fro within itself it has been
expelled from its kingdom or this
kingdom has been ransacked since the
waking consciousness has monopolized
every distinction an expansion of it and
has vindicated Earth's ownership of
every portion of it and given them back
to earth yet faith is not on that
account satisfied for this illumination
has everywhere brought to light only
single separate entities so that what
speaks to spirit is only a reality
without any substance and a finitude
forsaken by spirit since faith is
without any content and it cannot remain
in this void or sense in going beyond
the finite which is the soul content it
finds only the void it is a sheer
yearning its truth and empty beyond for
which a fitting content can no longer be
found for everything is bestowed
elsewhere faith has in fact become the
same as enlightenment that is the
consciousness of the relation of what is
in itself finite to an absolute without
predicates and absolute unknown and
unknowable but there is this difference
the latter is satisfied enlightenment
but faith is unsatisfied enlightenment
however we shall see whether
enlightenment can remain satisfied that
yearning of the troubled spirit which
mourns over the loss of its spiritual
world lurks in the background
enlightenment itself bears within it
this blemish of an unsatisfied yearning
as pure object in its empty absolute
being as action and movement in going
beyond the its individual self to an
empty and unfulfilled beyond as an
object with a content in the lack of
selfhood and the thing that is useful
enlightenment will rid itself of this
blemish a closer examination the
positive result which is its truth will
show that in that result the blemish is
in principle already removed
we reached the end of this section now
here in paragraph five hundred and
seventy three in which Hegel tells us
this is really the crux of of this this
passage here that faith really amounts
to a kind of unsatisfied or unfulfilled
enlightenment we saw at the very
beginning of this in the discussion of
the relationship between faith and pure
insight that they were both types of
thought that they are more closely
connected together and related in their
opposition to each other as modes of
thought then either of them are to the
world of culture that they they surpass
and and transcend so how does faith
become unsatisfied enlightenment we've
seen a lot of the development of this as
enlightenment carries on its critique of
faith but the absolute turning point is
that faith in effect loses its content
he says faith has lost the content which
filled its element the element of
thought and it collapses into a state in
which it moves listless Li to and fro
within itself so there is still a
consciousness of faith but it's in
effect a ruined consciousness it's one
that has lost its object that no longer
possesses the certainty that marked
faith it has become critical but it
hasn't gone beyond that yet so Hegel has
this beautiful metaphor here it's been
expelled from its kingdom the kingdom of
spirit in essence right it's been
expelled from its kingdom or this
kingdom has been ransacked the
barbarians are no longer at the gates
they've already broken in whether
through the front gate or through the
back door and they've taken everything
of value all of the content that made
faith what it was that allowed it to
have its attraction for the one entering
into it and a lot of to have its
fascination for one remaining within it
so he says the waking consciousness what
is the waking conscious we just talked
about this in
last passage the consciousness of the
everyday of the sensuous world it has
broken in he says it has monopolized
every distinction and expansion of it
and has vindicated Earth's ownership of
every portion of it and given it back to
earth giving it back to the world of
sense giving it back to the common
sensical the everyday the person of
understanding we might say the person of
insight the non-religious person the
secularizing person what does it mean to
say that Hegel is being rather
metaphorical here think about the sorts
of critiques that were indeed carried
out by those who were engaged from
sometimes within religious institutions
sometimes from without in criticizing
religious institutions in particular and
also in general they found ways to
naturalize religion and to say well
whatever you're calling beyond nature
the supernatural that doesn't really
make sense you can't explain it I mean a
great example of this is Humes dialogues
on natural religion where you see these
three interlocutors none of which who
completely represent humor
he's playing them all off against each
other as sort of he's the voice of
enlightenment right they're being made
to combat each other and ultimately
deprive each other of the content that
they they could have so he says
faith is not on that account satisfied
this illumination has everywhere brought
to light only single separate finite
only in the German entities so that what
speaks to spirit II says is only a
reality something that is actual without
substance everything has been
disconnected from each other does this
this sort of criticism sound familiar I
mean it should because if you think
about the critiques that were made
by so many people whether religious or
non-religious about you know modern life
and it's mechanization and what can
capitalism does you see these same
criticisms being made don't you Oh
everything has been everything is lost
its Center you know the beautiful
illusions that we have have been dashed
there's no connection between things
anymore
everybody has been atomized everything
has been turned into a mechanism with
interchangeable parts that's in effect
how the person of faith is feeling in
relation to the Enlightenment
without actually talking about those
sorts of things so in a way the
dialectic of faith and enlightenment is
a precursor to the dialectic between say
romanticism and whatever you want to
oppose it to so he goes on and he says
since faith is without any Content faith
has lost its content the spiritual world
has been ransacked and it cannot remain
in this void or sense in going beyond
the finite which is the soul content it
finds only the void faith becomes a as
Hegel says a sheer yearning it's truth
and empty beyond faith has to face up to
what enlightenment turned the divine
into a void absence of predicates
something about which all you can say is
it is or even perhaps not even it is but
we must postulate this as as something
even though we can never prove it does
that sound like anybody that you might
know from from history recent history
before Hegel somebody who wanted to
clear away knowledge to make room for
faith but what kind of faith a faith
that turns out to be and this gives it
away a religion within the limits of
reason alone well that is what is going
on here and the question is can this be
enough for the consciousness of faith is
void what what becomes of faith
says it turns into a shear yearning it's
a desire that doesn't know anymore what
it is desiring and it's a desire that
cannot be satisfied with a mere void
because it's already a void right the
void is within the consciousness of
faith and it's this object that's a very
unhappy place to be in many respects so
he goes on and he says everything is
bestowed elsewhere faith has in fact
become the same as enlightenment it
winds up taking on the same ultimate
perspective as enlightenment what is
what is he defining as enlightenment
here the consciousness of the relation
of what it is itself finite to an
absolute without predicates an absolute
unknown and unknowable
that's an interesting definition for
enlightenment isn't it this conscious
relation of something that is finite to
the absolute probably not a definition
you're gonna hear from too many people
but it does make good sense within both
the historical dialectic as we see it
playing itself out and within the
Hegelian narrative that is being
portrayed here so he says there is a
difference though enlightenment is
satisfied enlightenment faith is
unsatisfied enlightenment it cannot be
happy with being a void that reaches out
to another void that is not going to cut
it and yet it can't go back to you know
it's old forms of action and belief
because those have been turned into
merely finite realities that cannot
symbolize the absolute so he says we're
going to have to check though and here's
where we make the transition into the
next section of spirits which is called
the truth of enlightenment right now
even up until this point we've been
looking at the struggle of enlightenment
with with with superstition
and thereby with faith enlightenment
becoming successful is now going to have
to turn its powers upon itself and see
whether it truly is satisfied so Hegel
says we'll see whether enlightenment can
remain satisfied it is satisfied at this
point it's satisfied so long as it has
faith to surpass faith to put in its
place
he says the yearning of the troubled
spirit which mourns over the loss of its
spiritual world lurks in the background
so what we've got going on here very
interestingly faith was able to be
thrown down by the Enlightenment because
it had so much in common with the
Enlightenment and that is going to turn
out to be a bit of a Trojan horse for
enlightenment that was the door through
which enlightenment could come in and
ransack the spiritual kingdom of faith
but that door remains open and that void
that yearning now can come through that
that that door and enter into
enlightenment and there may be some
ransacking going on in the house of
enlightenment within the world within
Earth as well well that's going to
happen in the next section
so Hegel says enlightenment itself bears
within it this blemish of an unsatisfied
yearning as pure object in its empty
absolute being as action and movement
and going beyond its individual self to
an empty and unfulfilled beyond as an
object with the content in the lack of
the selfhood and the thing that is
useful so the very characteristics of
enlightenment produce its own
dissatisfaction I mean this should be
sort of a cautionary moment to those who
are the defenders the contemporary
defenders of enlightenment against
whatever they they pose as being you
know it's nemesis post-modernism is a
form of modernism that goes beyond this
particular modern and and sets up
something else and it does so precisely
because the modern is a
unfinished product project and it can go
off in different directions and it is
self-aware in this respect Hegel is
postmodern and so is the Enlightenment
when it stays true to itself so in a
sense we can talk about a superstition
or a faith of enlightenment that many
people are living out by not taking
cognizance of the fact that
enlightenment relates itself to an
absolute that is a void and it does so
in Hegel says determinate ways as pure
object as action and movement and object
with the content and we're going to see
him working these out as we move into
the next section so he's going to finish
this by saying enlightenment will rid
itself of this blemish a closer
examination of the positive result which
is its truth will show that in the
result the blemishes in principle
already removed but we have to ask
ourselves is that really the case as we
move now into the next section and I'll
remind you that after this truth of the
Enlightenment section we're going to get
to another very interesting part called
absolute freedom and the terror so the
truth of enlightenment is not going to
actually keep us out of the terror that
is going to be something that culminates
at the end of this process now we can
close the book on this particular
section seeing that enlightenment is now
the main object for the phenomenologist
to scrutinize as we work through it